speaking of [ __ ] online i i want a
quick rant
okay um because i know we've talked
about attack on titan like plenty
all right all right here we go all right
it's the greatest weekly attack on the
week
the weekly attack and titan rant segment
um
i'm getting so [ __ ] tired of spoilers
it's it's gotten to the point now
where my enjoyment of this is getting
[ __ ] ruined
because of spoilers online like logging
on
logging on to twitter now on especially
on a monday
right it's it's like i'm trying not to
be spoiled on the attack on titan it's
like trying to go to like a crowded
hospital
without a face mask and expecting not to
get covered that's like
it's i've been spoiled now on so many
plot points of attack on titan that i
feel like
as someone who likes to bin shows and as
someone who doesn't want to
i don't want to keep up with it like
weekly right but i feel like
i've i feel like i'm being held at
gunpoint just to keep up with this
weekly
i know i feel you on that you should uh
go through the wiki
um and get every character name and you
should mute them on twitter
that's what i've done have you done that
i've done that and yet still
like i would be on a random thread it
seeps through the cracks
there's no way to stop the cracks and
what i understand what i don't
understand
is why is it that you know when we talk
about spoiler culture
why is it that with a show like attack
on titan it's fine to talk about it as
soon as it airs it's because everyone
expects all the taglineton fans expect
that everyone is watching it
as the episode because it comes out
because because like with something like
this
you think it's not okay to talk about it
after it is
i mean i i think there should be a buff
appear like we had this for the avengers
why can't we not have this for attack on
titan or any other tv show
period i don't know yeah i mean there
was a massive [ __ ] buffer period
where like the directors
and everyone was just like please do not
talk about the avengers end game
for like a good two three weeks and
there there is just no
buffer period for like tv shows and like
we're living we're living in an age
where it's like on demand so it's it's
not even the same as it was before
where things are airing on tv and people
watching at the same time
everyone's watching at different times
it's it's literally an on-demand service
i don't know i really like the community
aspect of you know when an episode airs
everyone talks about it i kind of like
that no but there are ways to talk about
it in ways that are not spoiling yeah
and and there are places there are like
open forums that you have to physically
when i talk about the show on twitter i
try not to mention supposed videos
every tweet you've you've tweeted about
attack on titan it's fine because you're
not you're not spoiling it but you
still leave open for discussion right
yeah but i mean
i still need it right now there are some
[ __ ] kids who just do not understand
that and they're just like yeah
of course everyone is watching this 4k
picture
yeah i can't believe this character dies
yeah yeah exactly
and it's like there's like some
[ __ ] who will literally like
put a full spoiler and then like put a
spoiler warning five minutes after they
just spoil
the [ __ ] thing they talked about man
it's it's right now social media is like
treading a minefield i've never i've
never understood
the whole like spoiler warning at the
beginning of a tweet it's like how about
you just don't tweet it
actually it's i honestly not gonna lie
to save me a few times really because
i'll
i'll read the top of it about a show and
i'll see a picture and i'll quickly
scroll because i'm like oh it's sick
there's that's following actually
to me it's just the most pointless
[ __ ] warning it's better than nothing
right no i would rather just you not
spoiling it to be honest but i
understand
right because you know you know attack
on titan i wish i could
tweet about like the details of the show
a little bit more but i know that
because i have
like quite a large following that yeah
i'm gonna spoil it for someone's i don't
want to do that right yeah
but like i literally like every time you
think that
if you go on twitter on a monday in
japan oh it's on youtube
and you haven't watched the newest
episode that's obviously that's kinda on
you
well thanks for the victim blame that so
if you guys don't know
attack on titan airs i think in the
evening in america but and it has like 5
a.m on a monday
for us so first thing i do every monday
when i wake up is i watch the episode i
don't open twitter i don't do anything
because
i'm not being funny i know the internet
they're gonna spoil it there's nothing
you could say here or ever do that will
stop them from doing that so why not
just watch it
i feel though that this attack on titan
incident is like almost unprecedented
like i don't think there's ever been an
anime that has been
where the amount of spoilers on twitter
has been this problem
there's been none and i i remember
because attack on titan season three
part two i thought
you know i got spoiled on some like
minor things but like i don't see that
many spoilers online i see a [ __ ] i
see
i see it in the twitter trending page
yeah like that's how you know it's
getting bad
when literally on the when you go to
twitter trending some weeks and i've
seen it
some weeks it's it shows you the the
tagline or the hashtag or whatever word
is trending and then
underneath it gives the spoiler
that has never happened like recently i
i got or like i knew
like it's it's the equivalent of being
like yo something's going to happen with
this character you know yeah
you know nine times out of ten it's
probably a death yeah
it's probably going to be a pretty death
and the problem is that attacking titans
what is
one of the easiest one of the easiest
like shows to spoil out there because
all it takes is like one sentence
or one word i'm pretty sure i've seen
pictures of stuff
of like you know where like the current
manga is at
and that like i'm sure that's i've seen
very glimpse mix
when i see it and i recognize a
character i'm like i skip but
i've seen it and i i don't know what it
is so i'm like well if i have no context
this picture i don't know what's going
on
i'm not gonna be spoiled until the
moment i see that frame but okay i
i i actually disagree i disagree too
because because like
it i mean it still like spoils your
experience a bit because there's been
like for example there's been so many
like let's say anime or manga or ma
or where you see like a meme panel right
and this meme gets passed around and you
don't know the context of it
but um but then you finally read
or watch whatever shows everyone's memes
about and then it could be like this
really some of the most serious
moments in like media has been like just
ruined for me
because i've seen the meme of it and so
the moment happens and it takes you out
and be like
oh that was that was the moment they got
memed like right now i'm reading i'm
reading tokyo ghoul
because i want i want to see if the
tokyo ghoul manga readers are right and
i know
when that [ __ ] kaneki panel comes up
i'm gonna laugh
like i don't know what the context of it
is but
no it's not fun because to me like i've
had this happen where
i i'm not saying that it's okay to post
pictures from the manga
i i don't think anyone should be
a fraction of a second right like and
that way just like no i'm not gonna
watch it
somewhere in the back of your head that
image is subconsciously planted no no it
is right
yeah but here's what i've realized right
when you see an image
of a show right that you are you're
really into and it's like
it could be ages away you are
making your own theory in your head of
why that image is happening right yeah
if you've seen it right yeah
and so most of the time you're gonna be
wrong right
you're not it's not going to be accurate
so are you are you technically spoiled
because
you you've sort of seen something that's
given you a vague idea of what you think
could be happening but you could be
totally wrong
i honestly want to come into a show with
uh
what i'm saying is that like if seeing
one frame of a
panel of a monger an anime you know
obviously if it's literally a character
dead on the floor
yeah yeah yeah i mean that's being
heavily posted around but if there's
you know a shot of something happening
that i can't quite make out i don't look
at it long enough i just have some kind
of vague
feeling in the back of my head i don't
really think that's a spoiler because
he's because
something like that happened when i
decided to finally watch demon slayer
and like you know the the first example
we ever had at that was when episode 19
was
trending on twitter right and everyone
was posting pictures and gifs of
that scene yeah right and of course
because i knew immediately on the
training page it says demonstrate
episode 19.
and at that point i hadn't started here
right and i'm like well i eventually
want to get to it so obviously i'm not
going to look at it i'm going to try and
avoid
all pictures but obviously when you're
on twitter or you're on the internet
you're going to see like the fraction of
a frame a fraction of an image right
and not gonna lie when i finally caught
up the demon slayer and i got to that
scene in episode 19 i was like this is
impressive
but i feel i would have been even more
impressed if i had
no idea that this was coming like
everybody else and i had no experience
yeah
i know that doesn't take away a little
bit it does take to be honest
i i feel like it does absolutely i can
understand that but i don't know i was
like this is epic but this could have
been
[ __ ] mind-blowing like it was for
everybody else because